hey folks dr. Mike here I'm about to
play the game idle human but check out
this funny shirt someone sent mean it's
perfect for a day like today where we're
just gonna sit back have fun and play a
medical game tap here to start human
creation tap tap tap
to create cells cells are required to
form the human and it looks like the
faster I tap it alright so we just built
up the tarsals the metatarsals now we're
building up the tib-fib the tibia and
the fibula which are the shin bones oh
the skull is made up of 29 different
bones the more you know a single human
brain generates more electrical impulses
in a day than all the telephones in the
world well there's so many fun facts
here we should call this fun fact game
50,000 cells in your body died and were
replaced by new ones while you were
reading the sentence now we're building
the thigh bone which is called the femur
it's actually one of the strongest bones
in the human body but we got to build it
up right-handed people live on average
nine years longer than left-handed
people I know a large part of that has
something to do with workplace accidents
most tools are designed for right-handed
people actually said that in my medical
means upper stood about two thirds of
people tilt their head to the right when
kissing when you brush your stomach also
turns red actually it might be true
because there's a lot of histamine
release that occurs in your stomach
human beings are the only living things
which sleep on their backs come on
there's no way that's true Oh unlock the
pelvis bones now I'm building up the
hands which contained the metacarpals
and the carpals then we're gonna start
building up the forearm which contains
the radius and the ulna bones why is the
pelvis so expensive
I just got double the speed the sound
might be getting annoying but I'm
growing the human body
come on build that body build that body
build that body the total weight of the
bacteria in the human body is 2 kilos oh
it's almost 5 pounds of bacteria
my hand is fatiguing but I want to get
it 1 billion cells let's grow those
hands oh I'm ready onto that humerus
baby there are more than a hundred
different viruses which cause a cold
this is actually a great talking point
because when patients come into like
which virus do I have them like it
doesn't matter they're like please test
me will you pay for it cuz your
insurance law it's like no oh my god if
I don't at least finish a leg right now
I'm gonna be upset Oh
the legs are complete as in the stomach
oh look at that the stomach is building
rather quickly
oh I unlocked the liver my fingers
getting so tired you have no idea I
think this is something that I have to
like sit for days and hours I love
matcha it makes me feel loved my chest
is back oh what's I get 3,200 now oh my
god I'm gonna win this game so easy
right now lay down
oh we finished the hands legs and hands
done it says my human is seven percent
completed I will not stop this game
until I complete this human the secret
is to like vibrate your hands kidneys
unlocked and my biceps getting tired
look at that I got the ribcage see they
try to hold me down but I'm ready
there you go heart is on lock now look
at my human coming together brain is on
lock yay I got a do 1.2 trillion to get
the brain upgraded that's too much the
cerebral cortex is popping off the
medulla oblongata that ribcage looks
real alright one more 1.7 billion to
unlock the spine hey you got a spinal
cord is unlocked
yay let's upgrade the spinal cord three
point six trillion cells that's
ridiculous it's trying to hold us back
but I'm not gonna let us you're on my
team a yo-yo yeah now in order to build
the next organ which is the skull we
need the nerves at a thousand it's so
slow lay down
oh honey 1.2 trillion trillion see I've
been investing in this tapping thing
maybe the tapping thing wasn't a way to
go the human is 25% ready look at that
the mouth is a lot
I'm telling you our bodies at 40% we're
on fire now one eternity later though
ears are unlocked my iPhones probably
like your screen time is through the
roof what are you doing dr. Mike by the
way I don't recommend this to anybody
yeah we unlock blood leg muscles unlock
this person starting to look like a
human half of my human is done I don't
think anyone's ever finished this game
in one session all my organs are
complete all my bones are complete the
only thing that's left is like little
organs this is very doable look at the
head muscles are all done oh my God look
how what the body looks I haven't even
looked at it the pecs are coming in oh
let's build these leg muscles squats for
days baby all the muscles are complete
all the bones are complete all the
organs are complete the brain is now
complete the spinal cord the nose is
about to be complete the mouth is
complete the ears are complete I'm
building up the skin look at the skin Oh
10 trillion for a piece of skin that's
ridiculous it's damn high
he's looks too muscular and puffy though
finish that skin hair is a lock I think
I'm done congratulations completed I
need to synthesize his genes his
clothing this crazy that they threw and
clothing yourselves don't make clothing
folks I'm doing this strictly for you to
watch me suffer this is crazy I'll never
be able to finish this I completed his
jeans I like this shirt his hoodie
I got a do his hoodie now this is
absolutely I quit it should I do it no I
can't do it I just spent $21 on this
game this is a lesson to everyone at
home because the whole purpose is to get
you to spend money I know this would be
a good learning opportunity instead all
I learned is that I'm a susceptible
sucker oh my god I spent too many hours
doing that I put together a playlist for
you my favorite games watch those
there's something to learn there we can
have fun you don't have to watch me
suffer be happy and healthy if you watch
that and I'll see you over there
[Music]